>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Welcome viewers.
My name is Dan Sheehy,
Director and Curator Emeritus
of Smithsonian Folkways Recordings.
And it's my pleasure to have
been here today at a concert
in the Library of Congress sponsored
by the American Folklife Center
that featured three extraordinary
musicians from Albuquerque,
New Mexico, at least
where they live right now.
A trio lead by the great
oudist from Baghdad originally
and now a long-time
American citizen,
refugee from the Saddam
Hussein regime playing oud,
composer as well.
Just recorded a new
album coming out in 2017
with Smithsonian Folkways
Recordings,
accompanied by Sourena
Sefati, a Persian oud--
sorry, a Persian santour player.
Santour is one of my most favorite
instruments in the world by the way;
I hope you enjoy it as well.
He also lives in Albuquerque.
He's been there a little
over a year from Iran,
and also the great percussionist
and discipline and protégé
of Rahim AlHaj, Issa
Malluf, playing a host
of different musical instruments.
And now, it's a great pleasure
for me to ask you to join us
in a conversation with the
great oudist, Rahim AlHaj.
Rahim, it's great to
be together again.
>> Rahim Alhaj: It's great to be
with you always amigo, you know?
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yes.
I especially like this
very elegant stage setting.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Isn't it?
This is [inaudible]?
>> Daniel Sheehy: Like we're
really indulged with it.
[ Laughter ]
So, listen.
So, we've talked many times before
but I don't think we ever
really talked about, you know,
just right from the
basics, you know.
Like for example, tell us
about, what was it like--
what family were you born into?
You know, what was it like
family life when you are young
as far as you can remember?
Where was it-- You know, what
was day to day life like, as--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: -- as far
back as you can remember?
>> Rahim Alhaj: I was born in
Iraq, Baghdad, in an area--
it's called the Thawra,
the revolution.
And for actually poor people
who are after the revolution
against the royalty's
family in Iraq.
And so they give them--
each family are given one--
or a person actually-- a piece
of land to build their house.
But it's limited.
It's like 145 meters,
something like that.
And we are-- I'm the
youngest of my family.
We are a big family actually.
I have five sisters
and two brothers.
And, I was born as a
miricle like my mom said,
because she had me when she was 45.
And 45 during that time in
1968, is like a miracle.
No woman can get birth
through that time.
It could happen here and
there about within that frame
of [inaudible] things its a miracle.
So I'm born when I was for--
my mom like I said, 45.
When I grow up, I don't remember
really my mom was my mom,
because she's old.
It's like my grandma.
So my sisters-- they
took care of me.
And that's what I think
they are my mother and that
because she has white hair.
And my mom is the most beautiful
woman I've ever really seen.
And, she's so wise to the point
like she framed and I gave her a lot
of credit of making Rahim
AlHaj as a musician.
And my father was a typical
Middle Eastern father who is--
his power and his authority
has to be in a place
and the kids has to
follow the rules.
And I call him the stick, actually.
So-- And my mom she's, you know,
is ruled that kind of house.
And because I'm different
and because I was born
in different time, in
the wrong time, right,
to my father according to my mom.
And so, I started my life
with this kind of environment
of beautiful people who
loves me and adore me
because I'm the youngest, right?
And I'm their toy because they
don't have kids that time.
There's nobody.
So, since-- then I started
my initiation to music.
And like I said, again,
when my mom played a role--
a huge role in my music career and
my personality at the same time.
I remember so vividly, one
day when I was in practice--
I practice a lot and my
father doesn't need me
to be a musician, never ever.
And in fact, I remember so vividly
that he hold a gun actually one time
and he put it to his head.
He said, "If you really continue
music, I'm going to kill myself."
So, he needs me to
do something else.
And I did, actually.
In fact, I went to-- And I studied
Arabic literature with music
in conservatory--
Baghdad Conservatory because
that's the only way I can continue
studying music.
But I remember my mom told him--
One day they have conversation
and she told him, "Can you please
don't give this kid a hard time,
because he will the most of
important oud player in the planet."
I don't know what that means,
really, when I'm a kid.
I'm like seven years old, you know?
It's nothing.
It doesn't come to
me what's that mean
that your mother can see
this potential for a musician
in you and you have no idea.
All I can do is to play the oud.
So, I remember one time,
I was practicing at night
and usually I developed a really bad
habit sleeping with my instrument.
I mean, I can't for five
years, I cannot go to sleep
if I don't have my instrument.
So I cover it with a blanket.
I kiss it.
And one time I was there and I
was really tired and I was talking
to the oud, "I'm sorry
baby, I'm really tired.
So can we play tomorrow,"
and like that.
And just like a real
person, you know?
So I cover it and I
kiss it and I cover it
and was father was passing by.
And he went to my mom and
he said, "Our son is insane.
We need to do something about it."
So I'm like [inaudible].
And-- So he really wasn't into music
but he has the most beautiful
voice I've ever heard in my life.
And when he sing, the depth
and the sensibility in it,
he took this voice to cry.
Because he came from-- And my mom
at the same time, they are cousins.
It came from a Marsh
Arabs in the south.
And the Marsh, as you
know, is just water, right?
That's how they-- and then when they
go to the boat from house to house
and there's the trees high.
So that's where they use
their voice, singing.
And he has absolutely
haunting voice, haunting.
I remember one time he was
singing and he went and grab my oud
and I want to know which kind
of maqam he used, you know,
what kind of maqam he sing to.
And my mom just stopped and
she said, "What are you doing?"
I said, "What?
I want play with him."
She said, "No, no, no, son.
He is actually crying.
Did you not see?"
I said, "No wonder why this is so
deep in sound of sadness in it."
After that, actually I remember
my mom bought me the first suit
when I went to perform.
I was in second grade
of-- in literature school.
And, you know, suit and
something like that.
And my father never actually
came to any of my concerts.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Can you remember
any of those songs that he sang?
Can you sing any of them?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, of course.
There's some maqams which
is really interesting
and very important in
Iraq, specifically.
We use maqam as [inaudible].
Now the south actually
is fascinating.
The maqam they use-- And that's my
theory when I did that in school,
when I was a student when I
graduated from a conservatory.
I did my paper of the difference
between the north and the south
over the maqam, how they
use it and how the Kurdish
and the north they use are different
from people who lives in Ahwar,
which is the Marsh
Arab, for example.
So and then I figured
out that all these people
who create their own
style and their own voice
but they have no idea what's called.
So when I go there, I said, well,
do you know this, for example,
you think of maqam bayati?
So all of them are maqam
bayati when you play it
but the emphasis is different.
So they call them by name,
Swherly [assumed spelling],
Nazry [assumed spelling],
Sultani, and name it.
Like, whether that
frame of bayati or saba.
So, I remember, for
example, when they said--
[ Singing ]
It's very haunting but sad.
It's like you're waiting
for something, you know?
And by in the north, they talk
about something else, like--
[ Singing ]
It's very short.
Because they live in the mountains
and they do not have the surrounding
because of the echo of
your-- is what it counts.
It's very interesting.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do they
sing words to those songs?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Absolutely.
>> Daniel Sheehy: All right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: And, you
know, I can bring in some song
but usually they talk
about their life,
their love for things
or missing things.
Most of them are missing things,
and because death is very profound
in their life, especially when
we're talking about at the south.
The south has very
interesting creature I call them
because they create
everything basically.
I mean, historically actually,
the Sumerian people
who lived in the south.
I mean, the Marsh actually just
last week, they announced it
as a heritage of UNESCO basically.
I mean, it took them that years.
I mean, they don't understand,
this is actually what the
Sumerian civilization has started,
literary there, you know,
from Ur, Lakish, and Kish.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: So, I started
with that environment of people.
Nobody-- Actually my
brother is a good artist
and very famous artist actually.
He's a visual artist.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What's his name?
>> Rahim Alhaj: He's named Salim.
And he-- My father was OK
with him because he just--
you know, he's a painter but
I am a troublemaker, right?
I'm the musician.
When I was in the second grade,
I remember this beautiful story
that I was in second grade and
my teacher, he's Arabic teacher.
He's not a music teacher.
And one day, he brought
the oud with him.
And he would sing to us.
He was a communist actually.
And, so he sings to us
and I was fascinated
by the sound, by the shiver.
And as you know, you
know, in Middle East,
a teacher is like a god, you know?
It is not like human
being, you know?
So you cannot just look
them to the eye, right?
So I was like this and I
wasn't courageous enough
to ask him, "Can I just touch it?"
And he looked at me he said, "Sure."
So I raised my hand
and he just touched it.
And there is something
profound and things come to my--
all of my body is just like, "Oh."
In fact, they have
chill, I remember.
So I couldn't sleep from the hand
that touched this instrument.
And next day or the day after,
I remember he brought it again
and I said, "Can I touch it?"
Because I have this beautiful
ecstasy when I just touch this wood,
you know, so soft and
like it's beautiful.
And he looked at me and said,
"Do you want to play it?"
I said, "Yeah."
So, he hold it to me and
he said, "Be careful."
And it was like really bigger
than me, you know, the oud.
So he hold it to me and
I tried to imitate him.
So I put my right hand and then--
like this and then
I put my left hand.
This is exactly like him.
And I was so nervous and he
strums something and he's shocked.
And he said, "Wow.
You want to be a musician?
Take it." Can you imagine--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Rahim Alhaj: -- a
teacher give you ouds
because of a new like instrument.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And you never
sing or played a note before?
>> Rahim Alhaj: No, in my life.
I mean, I heard it in
the radio or TV but--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Rahim Alhaj: So he started
actually teaching, you know,
basics of maqam [inaudible]
and major and minor.
And then the next day I was
just like doing something,
I have no idea what I'm doing.
The song-- And he just freaked out.
I mean, how do you know this?
You can play it but you do
not know which maqam is.
I said, "I have no idea."
So, by the second grade-- I mean
in third grade I did there my
first solo concert basically.
I was in elementary.
>> Daniel Sheehy: He let
you take the oud home or--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
In fact, that's a beautiful
story that.
You know, going home with
oud bigger then me, I can't.
I just can't let go.
So I asked him politely if I can--
if he can just walk me because
the kids they're going to take it
from me or they, you know,
usually they throw rocks
on you or things weirdly.
So he went with me to my home
and told my mom in that time,
and teacher is very respectful
and they respected that.
So, when the teacher come to your
home, it was like a big deal.
It's a huge deal.
So he told my mom, "Well, he
has really a great potential
to be a musician, and I
can see he's a musician.
And this instrument I'm
going to give it to him.
So he didn't steal it.
He didn't-- You know, that's his.
And I will teach him
little by little, you know?"
And she was thrilled.
Now the problem after
six months and he said,
"Rahim, I'm not a music teacher.
You need a real one who can teach
you, you know, how to either write
and system and theory
and something like that,
to be able to continue your career."
And then he followed me to
another teacher, [inaudible name]
which is wonderful human being
who taught me for I think,
one or two years at that time.
By then, I just find myself how
to create my own voice and own--
and I always was interested really
about peace and justice, you know,
social justice basically.
And we can talk to you
about it later about that.
But that's the environment
actually--
>> Daniel Sheehy: So
you're maybe 10 years old,
12 years old, or something
like that--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Correct.
>> Daniel Sheehy: --
now, right, actually?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
That time when I-- Yeah,
by 13, I started composing.
In fact, by 13, I win the national
youth, composer youth of Iraq.
>> Daniel Sheehy: We
heard one of your songs--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Correct, that's one.
>> Daniel Sheehy: -- at the concert.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Absolutely.
So--
>> Daniel Sheehy: That was it?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yes, that's the one.
And I compose it because it was
something that maybe, you know,
for them it was like
very interesting.
How this kid can take this
maqam dasht and transform it
to maqam bayati and make mode
of it with rhythm is called a--
it's very Iraqi rhythm, specifically
Iraqi rhythm culturally.
[ Singing ]
So it was innovative things
at that time, you know?
It's not-- So, since then, when I
win that composer for the youth--
composer in Iraq when I was 13.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What
year were you born?
>> Rahim Alhaj: 1968.
>> Daniel Sheehy: 1968.
So here we are at 70 or around--
>> Rahim Alhaj: 40--
>> Daniel Sheehy: -- 81?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yes, right.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Rahim Alhaj: After that, you
know, I was like became famous TV
and newspaper and magazine.
And-- But my father, he's
never took it seriously.
Never. He's never really--
we're watching TV and
newspaper and magazine.
I mean, big deal there, you
know, when you are in TV.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: It's a big deal.
And even in newspaper,
your picture, you know,
smiling or something like that.
But my father, I think, he-- he's--
I mean, when I look at him
right now, he did what he can.
He thought, you know,
being a musician it will
make me a troublemaker.
He doesn't know I'm a
troublemaker anyway,
you know, with or without him.
So that's actually the
environment that I grew up with.
>> Daniel Sheehy: In the concert,
I don't know if what the exact
story was but you mentioned counting
to four and that your
mother would give the kids--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What
was that about?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
This is a-- When I was there, you
know, always practicing always,
compose music and-- because it--
the oud to me, it was
my breath and still.
And I cannot breathe
without my-- never.
I mean, I never ever been away from
my oud except one year and a half
when I was in Brazil, you know?
And in fact I did-- I wrote my first
concierto actually in the prison.
But this piece actually,
I remember my mom used
to clap like, right, like that.
And she made up some
whatever Habibi,
sweetheart, to keep them down.
And I was like, "How this
Irish rhythm came to you?"
And then I find out,
well, actually yes,
because we are occupied
by Britain that time.
So, they brought this rhythm with
them and introduce it to Iraq
because this is-- we
have like for Georgina,
we have Laxom [assumed
spelling], we have, you know?
That's what the Iraqi-- specific
Iraqi but not one, two, three, four.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Usually we have 6/8,
we have 10/8, we have 32, you know,
like very complicated
rhythm not, you know,
some rhythms one, two, three, four.
So I-- I'm haunted by it.
I was like, well, this
is a beautiful tune
to compose on this-- in her memory.
Actually, I compose it for
actually string quartet that time.
By then I think as a musician,
as a human being, well,
you would be influenced around
what environment you live with.
Now, I'm-- why my generation
actually,
we are very unlucky
generation actually.
Because we-- I call them
the generation of war.
I grow up when the
Iran-Iraq war started,
which is eight years, right?
I mean, huge.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What
year would that have been?
>> Rahim Alhaj: It was
1980 and ended in 1988.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And as I recall,
more than a million
people died in the war.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Correct.
So we lost one million from the
Iraq and one million for Iran.
And that's beautiful, now we are
playing together-- the Iranian.
I mean, that's what's
significant about it.
By the way I remember so vividly, I
was in Paris at one time and there's
in Iran-- I never saw Iran.
I had never in my life.
I mean-- Because they
are our enemy, right?
That's how they show it
in TV and in the media.
So-- And I was in Paris and there
is an Iranian man who came to me,
in the concert, introduced
himself as an Iranian.
And I was shocked.
Because I never saw Iranian
human people as, you know,
just like touch me and--
because that's how I see it,
this war-- killing, death.
Because used to-- the
regime that time used
to show everyday, 8
o'clock at night.
In the national TV or to--
because we have one TV actually
with just two channel and owned--
of course controlled
by the government.
They have showed [foreign words],
is like pictures of battles.
So whatever the battles happen
there, you know, across the Iraq,
they show all these dead
people and soldiers of Iran.
And that's all the
picture of Iran I have.
It's fascinating.
So, years and years later, I'm
playing with Iranian musician.
So, I remember I had
a chill when this guy,
the Iranian is a human
being, in Paris.
That's why actually it
lead us to this point
that I figured out this is not fair.
This is-- When I come
back, I said, "No, no, no.
This is not fair."
There is no justification
for this war.
We lost one million people
and we have 600,000 disabled,
both sides by the way.
And I started protesting
the war and compose music,
actually criticizing the war,
criticizing the government
that time.
Which lead me to be in trouble
with the government that time.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What was the
song or the piece that you--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: --
an example or what?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Correct.
I remember I composed one
piece this called "Why".
Composed-- Actually written
by a dear friend of mine,
my childhood friend [inaudible
name] who is still alive actually.
Last year when I went there,
I was searching for him.
And we wrote-- he wrote
these lyrics about--
it's called "Why" [inaudible]
criticizing because that time,
we cannot say directly
what's going on.
We have to go, you know, around it.
I mean, we interpret
our poetry or music.
You cannot say "Saddam is a
dictator," we cannot say that.
So why was comparison
between good and bad,
to ask why there is rich
people and poor people?
Why there is hungry
people and not hungry?
Why there is justice and injustice?
We go on and on and
there's why, why, why.
So when you hear it,
you don't really prefer
to criticize the government.
You can defend it to some degree.
But I think the regime is smart
enough to figure out that.
And what happens later, actually,
this piece becomes
very popular in Iraq.
In fact, one time, I remember
so vividly, we sing in weddings.
In weddings.
And me and Drod [assumed
spelling] and friends,
[inaudible] was a friend of ours.
His brother was getting married,
which he didn't like that
in the wedding and
they stopped singing,
and they stopped singing
that "Why" song.
And Drod said, "I didn't
wrote this piece."
"You're the composer?"
I said, "I'm not the composer
of this piece," really.
So finally, you know, they
get-- they find out, you know,
who wrote this piece
and who has composed it.
He was very famous, you know?
They used in their
wedding, you know,
whatever things they
can have opportunity to.
Because for them, it's become
a voice, to what they hold
against the regime during that time.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And when
you say they found out,
you mean people in
the regime found out?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Correct.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Rahim Alhaj: The regime, you
know, they have a lot of mukhabarat,
you know, intelligence and
[inaudible] there which is very--
like any dictatorship
anywhere in the world
because they are very strong.
And Saddam was very
strong, a very strong person
who controlled the country
in very bad way, anyway.
So, soon they find out I'm the one.
And it was-- actually like
I said, I was speaking
out against the Saddam regime.
And then beyond.
You know, I thought I'm going
to change the regime,
of course, you know?
And I joined a lot of
group who believe in that.
And it was difficult at that
time because if you find out,
they want to execute
you no matter what.
So, actually, I fled to the North.
And I was the messenger
between the Baghdad
and the people who lives in--
>> Daniel Sheehy: At
Like Mosul or what--
>> Rahim Alhaj: No.
And it took in the Kurdish--
>> Daniel Sheehy: The Kurdish.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Kurdish.
That's why we played
this one-- Kurdish one.
So I spent for like one year
and a half, actually in prison.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And what--
how did that happened?
What-- So when you are in the North?
>> Rahim Alhaj: No, in Baghdad.
They catch me in Baghdad actually.
Not just me, there's a lot,
you know, of people who--
young and older people who--
from different kind of belief.
Actually, there is this Islamic
group and there's communist group
and there's a nationalist group
who is whatever somebody he is,
you know, poets, writer,
novelist, whatever who is speaking
out against Saddam
regime that time, he was--
they will end up to this matter.
So I remember so vividly one day
I get tired of it from the torture
of the day, you know, like, we
are very [inauduble] in room
with seven to eight feet.
We sleep in turn.
So I remember, all I needed that
time to save my fingers, all I need.
So, when they put you on the chair--
so I put my hands, I
will hide my finger.
Because they are stupid,
they need to charge me.
It's like spread my
fingers and that's it, done.
So I was hiding it and
make my body available.
So he can torture me as much as
he can but don't break my fingers.
That's all I need.
You know, for one year and a half--
And now actually I'm
talking about it openly,
for years it means I
couldn't really talk about it.
One day I've decided to
finish it, to end it.
Because the pain was too
profound and inconceivable
to some degree, you know?
You see your friend, you know,
everyday in turn, today is me,
tomorrow is Dan, tomorrow Sabah
[assumed spelling], Salim, whatever.
I decided this is it,
it's not worth it.
I have to finish it.
They way you have to
finish it is to--
I thought about it--
is to provoke this guy.
He can just beat me up to death.
So I started to provoke
him actually, to finish it.
But he didn't have-- He was
torturing me and blah, blah, blah,
blah, but he didn't have the
authority to finish it, to kill me.
But that was the moment I thought
this is it, I can't take it anymore.
But then, you know,
for 1 year and a half,
some of them actually it's
here, been here, you know?
And sometimes I'd just be
emotional when I go back to that.
I remember one time I
had a concert in Chicago.
And there's a dear friend of mine,
Basim, and actually he was here.
He came I think four
years after I came here
in 2004 or something like that.
So I have there and he came
and I said, "Well, look,
there's an Iraqi-- they told me
that there is an Iraqi
restaurant, they sell kebab.
You know, I would love to see this
because I haven't seen
it for a while.
They said, "Yeah, yeah.
There's a restaurant."
So we took a taxi and he knows where
the restaurant and we went there.
So I'm happy to see Basim.
And we seated there and
talk in the restaurant.
I'm pretty excited.
And there is a guy who
just go back and forth,
like a heavy guy and
was [inaudible].
And I don't know who is this guy,
but he was really staring to me
and look at me and
look at me [inaudible].
And 10, 5 minutes whatever
it is, and he came to me
and he said, "Do you know me?"
I said, "Not really.
You know, I see a lot of
people of everyday, you know?"
And that's true.
I have a problem with--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yes.
>> Rahim Alhaj: As you know.
>> Daniel Sheehy: I know you do.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
I have a problem with name and date.
So he said, "Do you remember me?"
And I said, "No, not really.
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry."
And he-- in one second,
he showed me his legs.
Just like that he took his
pants up and I saw his leg.
And I remember it just
came like that.
I started crying because
I know this leg.
I saved it.
In North he got shot by the regime.
And we are in the North, because we
fight in Saddam regime that time,
and he got shot by the Iraqi army.
And I tried, you know, really
to save his leg that time.
And I looked at him
and say, "Oh my god."
But, you know, he became
bald and, you know,
really-- I don't remember that.
He left in 1991.
And I haven't seen him for
like, what, 25 something years,
you know, more than that.
But I don't remember his
face but I remember his leg.
So, I went it and kiss it, you know?
I was like, wow, this is the leg
that I was crying and saved it.
And he came to United States, you
know, refugee like anybody else.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Wow.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Sometimes we think
of-- I mean, of course, you know,
after that they came
to the concert a lot.
And he's the owner
of that restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
The restaurant we went,
he is the owner of that.
>> Daniel Sheehy: In Chicago?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, in Chicago.
It's incredible.
So that environment, that's
what shaped, to be honest,
my music, the social justice.
In two topics, I'm fascinated by--
and actually not just fascinated,
I'm obsessive about talking about in
my music is in children and women.
Children and women is the most
important to me because children,
they do not have voice and
women at the same time.
Trying to be their voice, take
their stories and write it down
and take their story to be
heard so we can make a change.
So I'm really putting my
music in that direction.
Just women and children,
that's it, and of course that.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Could
you say a few words
about your memory of leaving Iraq?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
Yeah, actually, it was the
most and the most crucial--
crucial and more painful --
inconceivably, to my time.
Just because-- First of all, I
cannot leave Iraq because I am--
I was the black sheep, right?
I'm, like my father said,
a little troublemaker.
And my Mom decided to get me out.
I mean, the only way to get me out
is to buy me a travel document--
false travel document because
I cannot leave Iraq legally.
So, she-- a bribed a
guy, he said I'm going
to provide him the passport
and he needs 1 million
dinar which is $25,000.
That time was really 1981.
It was a lot of money and
it's still a lot of money.
So my Mom had to do anything.
I mean, she sold everything, all her
belongings including her clothes,
including her clothes just
to save me, to get me out.
And secretly nobody knows except
me and my Mom and brothers and her
and this guy who has to take me
from Baghdad to Jordan to Amman
with false [inaudible]
and a different name.
And it was difficult because I-- the
moment I put one step out my home,
the gate, and I was walking.
And then I said, "Just don't look"
because my father was sitting
and smoking his cigarette.
He said, if I look back,
I'm not going to go.
So, I took my oud and I let my
brother take my books, my suitcase
and from that other gate,
you know, outside the gate.
So I was walking.
Opened the gate and my
father is still smoking.
I just turned like that.
And he just looked at me like this.
He says, "Rahim, just
leave, just leave."
I left. And my brother and-- we
went there and the guy and I took
that taxi and we go to Jordan.
In the borders between Iraq and
Jordan, I didn't have anything.
I have my books and oud, that's it.
And I have mustache because we need
to make it something different.
That time, when you go out of Iraq,
you cannot take two things,
books and instrument.
It's illegal.
Unless you have a permission from
the Ministry of Culture saying, oh,
Rahim is doing concerts in Jordan
or whatever or United States,
so you are-- and you have the
permission from the Ministry
of Culture so you can
take your instrument
through otherwise there's
no way to--
for it to allow you to
take an instrument outside.
So when we get to the
border-- the custom, right?
And they took it, because
it was there.
And I said, "Where
are you taking that?"
And he said, "No, no.
You're allowed to take it."
I said, "No, no, no it's mine."
I said, what do you mean?
You're not.
Are you a musician?
And I said, "No."
"Do you have a paper from
the Ministry of Culture?"
I said, "No."
I said. "No, I do not."
So he took it and he sent it to, you
know, another room with this custom
where something that you're
not allowed to take with.
And they put it like [inaudible].
And I wasn't really-- I was furious.
I need my instrument.
Because this-- the
instrument I grow up with,
since I was seven years old,
until I became, what, 22, 23,
24 something like that
when I left Iraq.
I mean, it's not an
instrument to me, it's my life,
it's my breathe, like I said.
I grow up with it.
I became musician with it.
I became a human being
with it, actually.
So being-- leaving my
instrument behind, no, no,
this is not the question.
And I can't, because
I can't breathe.
So I went there to the
officer and I talked to him.
I was begging him, "Please,
can I have just my instrument?"
He said, "No, you can't."
And this guy, he was furious.
Because if we-- if he catch us-- not
just me, him, he will be in trouble,
he will be executed just like that.
So he was begging me, Rahim, just
please-- just move, just move.
Because they stamped
our passport, you know?
So, OK, I told him,
"No, no, no, I can't.
So we go and he was,
you know, really angry.
And he said, "Look, I
will bring it to you.
I promise I'm going
to bring it to you."
So I remember we go to the
bus and then I find myself
like I don't have my
instrument, I go back.
I'm running to him, begging him
and crying and crying and crying.
"Just give it to me
because I can't breathe."
And he said, "No, if you
want to go back, you go back.
Take it. If you back to Iraq,
there's no problem, take it,
but you cannot take it out."
So, in one second I get sick,
really, I get really ill,
in just a minute, I mean really ill.
I was shaking, you
know, like something.
My body couldn't take it.
The whole thing, my body couldn't
really handle that pressure too much
by -- afraid to be caught and
have my breath, I call it.
I can't really.
And this guy who I was
just begging to get in,
so he pushed me to the bus.
So we just passed the
boarders from Iraq to Jordan.
And that was the most difficult
and the most crucial
moment in my entire life.
I mean, torture I don't care,
but this one was really,
really important to me,
was really profound to me.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So, you went
from Jordan then to Syria?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And then
you had experiences in Syria,
you found something
special in Syria?
What happened then?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Right.
There in Jordan I was hiding
actually during that time.
And actually, before I will go
there which is beautiful but I need
to say something really,
really important about that.
This passport, I went-- I was
in Jordan because it was valid
for one year because it's different,
name is different, and it expired.
I cannot go anywhere.
There is my childhood friend,
his name is Aden [phonetic]
who lives in Frankfort now.
His brother Hamad Sudani [assumed
spelling] which is my dear friend,
also my childhood friend
who is the most famous, now,
visual artist in whole
United States,
I mean like hot, like
million and a half.
And he is a calligraphy guy.
He faked the stamp of
Iraqi embassy in Jordan.
He faked it.
He wrote it just like this,
as if it's like a stamp.
And we signed it and
valid for two years.
He faked it.
In Syria during that time
there is no relationship
to Israel-- Iraq, and Syria.
So everybody in Syria-- Iraqi
and Syria mean that he is
against Saddam regime
and vice versa.
All the Syrians against the
Syrian regime, they live in Iraq,
so they don't relationship now.
So, all the opposite groups
who worked against Saddam--
the other two countries, was
Syria and Iran at that time.
So, they get an invitation to go
to Syria, Damascus, to a concert,
which is all the opposite
groups they know who I am,
of course, you know, talk to them.
And they said, "Rahim, you need to
get out because Jordan is not safe."
I was hiding.
I don't need to see-- you
know, because the only country
at time period who is-- has a
normal relationship with Iraq.
After the invasion, everything
just collapsed, right?
So the only contact to the
world was Jordan, that's it.
So all the Iraqi police, they are
in Jordan, basically, you know,
because that's how they do it.
So I was hiding, like I said,
in that time until I get this
invitation to go to Syria,
Damascus to do this concert.
Long story short, I
went to Damascus.
And in Damascus, you know, when--
as soon as I cross
the border, I'm safe.
And they told the taxi
driver to stop, to stop.
And he said, "What do you want?"
I said, "To stop."
So I went out of the car and--
because the minute I put my foot
in the ground of Syria, this is it.
There's no return to
Iraq, that's it.
So, I kissed the ground
actually on Syria
and getting teary at that time.
And he said, "Why?"
I said, "This is Damascus."
The taxi driver said, "so what?"
But he didn't understand
what I'm talking about.
It's way, way, way, way, way
difficult for him to understand.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
you stayed for awhile?
>> Rahim Alhaj: It is really great.
In fact, I didn't want to
leave Syria-- in Damascus.
I stayed there for eight years.
In fact, my first-- my wife Nada,
she was a professional journalist.
And she came to interview me,
which is like one day or two days.
And I looked at her, she's
a beautiful, gorgeous,
you know, woman, right, Syrian.
And I said, "Well, could
you please marry me?
like that."
[ Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: There's
something--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Just like that.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Somehow
I believe that.
[ Laughter ]
>> Rahim Alhaj: She is
gorgeous, she's beautiful.
I said, "Could you please marry me?"
You know, Arabic woman, shy.
And we fall in love.
And I stayed for eight years.
And until 2000, actually, and
I came to the United States.
And back to the story of
the password-- passport.
So when you're out of Syria
basically you don't need anything,
you know, because you
are safe, right?
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: And you are
working with the opposite group
and Iraqi groups who
were against Saddam
and the government they don't
bother you with anything.
They really welcome you.
So I don't need the passport, right?
So what we do as an Iraqi,
at that time when we live
in Syria, is that we fake it.
The government, they told
us just to bring fake one,
and then you can leave, it's normal.
Because they know where
they're going to get, you know,
Iraqi-- normal Iraqi passport.
So we get basically from
the north, from the Kurds
who are giving them-- smuggling to.
And we go on different
name, language,
to Lebanon I was using
different name.
So, that time when I came to United
States, I said I don't need it.
So I give it to my friend Ahmed,
Ahmed Hashim who was living
right now in Iraq, who was the--
he's a beautiful, wonderful
scholar in French literature.
And now he actually has a
program, Iraq TV [inaudible].
I said, "Ahmed, take it."
Because the way you can get out
of Syria, you need passport.
So I gave it to him.
He faked it.
And he went to Belgium and
he get asylum in Belgium.
And he went back to Syria,
you know, just to visit.
And he called me.
He said, "Rahim, what will
I do with this passport?"
I said, "Just give it
to Nada," you know?
I was here, United States.
So he gave them back my passport.
You know, it's already expired, you
know, it's like long, all right?
So he gave it to them.
Until last year, I
went back to Baghdad.
And I talked to Nada.
I'm like, "Do you know what
happened to the passport?"
>> Daniel Sheehy: Nada is your wife.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, Nada my wife.
Sorry, I have to clarify that.
She said, "I think, Rahim, he gave
it to us and still in the house?"
I said, "It would be
great if I could have it."
So we called him and
said, yeah, we have it.
So I said, but now the-- because
the situation in Syria last year,
you can't, you know,
really do normal mail.
I said, can you please send it to
Lebanon and from Lebanon, you know,
send it in FedEx, whatsoever,
so I can get it?
So they went there and
they said, "No, no, no,
we cannot send a passport
document to America.
We can't."
Well, what can I do?
And then all of a sudden,
Nada's cousin who is working,
he is the head of the
Syrian airline.
He said, "I have an idea.
How about we send it with a
flight attendant in Damascus, huh?
And soon as they go
to Baghdad we give it
to somebody there and call you.
You can receive it in Baghdad.
Why you need it now?
Go to Baghdad then
you receive it there."
So, I went to Baghdad from
here, from New Mexico.
>> Daniel Sheehy: From the
States-- Yeah, from New Mexico.
>> Rahim Alhaj: I went back
to New Mexico and to Baghdad.
Two days, Nada called
me and she said, "Well,
here's the number you need to call.
This is the guy who
has the passport."
So, I called him and
he said, "Oh, yeah,
I have this old Iraqi passport.
What are you going to do with it?"
I said, "Nothing."
So, where do you leave blah, blah?
He said I'm at this hotel.
And we went, me and my brother
Salim and Hamad, my nephew.
So, I went to the hotel and called
him and he's coming back down.
I was waiting at the lobby.
And this guy, he came and he
said my name is such and such.
And he just gave it
to me, like that.
So, I just-- I look at it.
I was in tears.
And I said, I couldn't believe.
Oh, my god, this is passport.
I got it from Iraq who cost my mom
$25,000, and saved another life,
faked in Jordan, and I
received it in Baghdad.
That's doesn't happen
in novels, really.
If you need to write it in a
novel, you cannot write it--
the significant things about
that passport because --
issued in Baghdad after 25
years, I received in Baghdad.
I thought about that.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
it had a stamp by one
of Iraq's most favorite artists.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: A beautiful story.
Was that-- You visited a
music store at one point?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yes.
>> Daniel Sheehy: And you
returned from the States
to Baghdad, what year what that?
>> Rahim Alhaj: That was in 2004
after the invasion, actually.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What happen there?
>> Rahim Alhaj: This is
when the invasion happen,
of course that's the only way I
was able to return back to Baghdad,
because before that I can't.
And so as soon the invasion
happened and Saddam regime fall out,
and now I can, I can
go back to Iraq.
So I went in 2004.
So, I told Salim.
My brother said, you
know, what I need--
I need to go to places that I
used to go, you know, coffees
and friends meet and talk about
politics and philosophy and music
and art, and the record store
where we get our cassettes
and things like that.
I said, "Sure."
So we went there.
Tell him I need to go
L'Chaim [phonetic] Records,
it's called L'Chaim.
So, I told Salim, "Salim,
could you please tell him
if he has Rahim AlHaj CDs."
So he went there and he said,
"Do you have Rahim AlHaj CDs?"
He said "Who is Rahim AlHaj?"
He's Arabic what kind
of song he sing.
He said, "No, no, he's not a
singer, he's an oud player.
So there's a guy behind the counter,
he heard the name, and he came to me
and he said, "You mean Rahim AlHaj?
The oud player?"
He said, "Yes."
So he went back into
the store inside.
And two, three, five, six
minutes whatever, he came
and he brought a cassette
with my picture in it.
It's like stupid, you
know, posing like whatever.
It's young.
And he said, "You mean this one?"
And he said to him, "Yes."
In fact, this is the guy.
And he looked at me like, I couldn't
believe it-- he couldn't believe it.
So he went from there and he come to
me and he give me hug, kissing me.
He said, "Rahim, you
don't understand.
All these years during the
sanction of 13 years and more,
we've been copying this record,
I mean, secretly, secretly,
because it's the only voice for
us to be against Saddam regime.
And it's not illegal for us to--
" because it was illegal to
sell my cassettes in the stores.
So I look at it and I
just, again, I cried a lot.
I said, oh my god, you know,
like this is like,
what, 1982, '83, right?
So I look at it and he
said, "Take it, please."
And I said, no, it belongs
here, not to me, you know?
It belongs to Baghdad, not me.
I said, what am I going to do with
a cassette in the United States?
It's here.
He said, "Could you please
just sign it for me?"
So I signed it for him.
And I thought, wow, you know,
that's how-- I left some impact.
I made a difference.
When this guy was telling
me, he said, "Rahim, no,
we've been copying it and
give it to people who need
to see Rahim AlHaj,
Rahim AlHaj, you know?
And I'm not a singer,
I'm a composer, you know?
I'm an oud player.
So it was really significant to him.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Do
you have a photo of that
or any copies of it or anything?
>> Rahim Alhaj: I think,
yes, I do to some degree.
I mean, when I went back,
there is a mixed feeling
down that time when I first visit.
It was very emotional visit.
I mean, different form last
visit which is last year.
This because I had an idea, all
my pictures, all the pictures
who was saved, and most of
them actually they destroy,
just because they don't
need any document
about me even though
they know who I am.
Somehow they figured out.
So, it came to the idea, I
said, you know, all this memory
and all these pictures belong
here, not belong to me.
I don't know, I get
this, now I regret it.
And I have to bring-- I
mean, I get some of them.
And now actually my brother, he
said-- posting them, you know,
on his page, and said nobody
will know Rahim AlHaj, you know,
what he was, you know, seven
or eight-- the first concert,
second concert in Iraq and Bagdad.
That time, you know, I was--
and I toured the world with the
most famous important musician
in the whole planet
in oud, Munir Bashir.
And he was my teacher for six years.
And I had the privilege
actually to be with him.
And I had-- you know, I
was-- not just privilege,
I was actually fortunate.
I mean, even though actually
he was-- God bless his soul,
he believed in me as musician but
he needs me to be part of the regime
and I was refused to do that.
By then, I felt like every
memory, every things that--
books, and pictures, letters,
that belongs to them not
belong to me, to some degree.
>> Daniel Sheehy: So,
why the United States?
[ Laughter ]
In the all-- the whole
resettlement experience,
what are some memorable stories?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Well, yeah,
this is really interesting--
not just interesting, this
is like hilarious, actually.
When I was in Syria, I wasn't
really-- want to leave Syria,
because Damascus and Sham
is the most beautiful piece
of land on Earth, really.
I mean, I toured the world and
I saw literally all the world.
But Damascus and Sham has
something as-- it's unbelievably--
not normal, in a good
way not the bad way.
Damascus I call like a mother,
you know, who care about her kids
but she doesn't know why.
There's a street you walk
in and it's 5,000 years old.
And not only, you know, go and
visit and take picture of it.
No, no, we live in it.
The most beautiful people
and gorgeous women--
all of them gorgeous,
there's nothing that's wrong.
I have one of them.
So, I wasn't really-- you know,
I don't need to leave Syria
because I was able to--
I have a fake passport
that allowed me to leave, right?
And I'm safe.
Until 2000, the guy,
he said [inaudible],
he was the executive
director of the settlement
in Syria of the UN settlements.
And he-- I had a call from him and
he said, "Rahim, I need to see you."
"Well, what do you want?"
He said, "No, no.
Come over tomorrow."
So I went there.
The only thing he said, "I
don't need to talk to you a lot.
I have one message to
you, which is leave."
I said, "Why?"
He said, "I cannot give
you an answer, just leave.
And here's the deal, you have
no choice except United States
of America."
I said, "No, I don't need to
go to United States of America.
Why do I need to go there?
Tell me why?"
He said, "I cannot give
you more than that.
It's up to you.
If you want to leave,
just let me know.
I need the answer tomorrow."
Well, I went back to Nada
and I told her, Nada,
well, here's the story, right?
I mean, Hamid told
me that that I have--
the only choice is
United States of America.
I need to go to America and I'm
not really interested to go there.
She said, "Rahim, just go there.
If you like it, fine.
If you don't like it, just
come back, it's that simple."
So I called him and
I said, "Yeah, fine."
Two days, I was in Albuquerque,
in two days, literally.
Everything, they made it like that.
And I bought my ticket, in fact,
even Nada didn't come with me.
She said, Rahim, just go.
And then she will follow you
soon as she gets [inaudible].
And I end up in Albuquerque,
New Mexico.
And I chose that just
for two reasons, really.
One reason because I'm a musician
and I'm interested in arts,
and that's my passion to write
for art, critique, art critique.
Critic, that's what
they call it, right?
And they told me that
Santa Fe and Taos
and New Mexico is very
important for arts and in music.
And the second reason was the
desert, like Middle East, right?
So I end up there.
And I didn't understand really
quite sure what I could do there,
you know?
What can I do, where I
can continue my life?
Courageously enough,
I accepted and I went.
And they gave me $60.
They bought all my
cigarettes in there.
And then one month later,
my case worker came to me.
And he said, "Hey Rahim,
we found you a job."
I said, "Sure."
I didn't speak English at that time.
I mean, I can communicate,
but not really.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Did
he speak Arabic or--
>> Rahim Alhaj: No.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Or he
spoke to you in English?
>> Rahim Alhaj: He speaks
to me in English, yeah.
And he said, we found you
a job and I said, "Sure.
Where is the job?"
And he said in McDonald's.
I don't know where
the McDonald's is.
I said, so which kind
of conservatory is that?
They teach just classical--
western classical music strictly
or they have branch of, you
know, eastern classical music?
And he smiled and he said, "No.
It's a McDonald's."
I said, "Yeah, yeah,
McDonald's, yeah.
So which kind of institute is that?"
He said, unfortunately it's not
an institute, it's a restaurant.
And I said, "But I
don't play restaurants."
[ Laughter ]
I don't play in restaurant.
He said-- Well, he said, well,
you're not playing there, actually.
I said, so what do you want to do
with this McDonald's,
whatever they call it?
He said, well this is a restaurant
and you need to work
as a dishwasher.
I just lost it.
So whatever bad word I already
learned, I throw them to him.
I said, "No, no, no, no.
You know who I am?"
He said, yeah.
I mean, we know you are
one of the blah, blah.
You are an important
musician in the world,
but you must make it--
you must make a living.
I mean, you have to work and that's
the only job we find you for now.
I said "No, no, no.
Just could you please
send me back to Damascus?"
You know, when I came back, I
went to United States, again,
I have books, oud, and a lot of
important paintings, that's it.
It's all I have.
Again, that's another,
you know, station.
You know, I have to take another
chapter of the same oud traveling,
you know, from continent
to continent.
I said, no, no, no,
I want to go back.
He said, well, yes, but
if you want to go back,
you have to pay your ticket.
The one you-- Not just the one you
came in, the one you-- going back.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Oh.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Well,
I don't have it.
I don't have the money.
It's like $4,000, $5,000.
And I said, "Well, now what?
I'm stuck?"
I have dear friend of mine,
she is a wonderful human being.
She is still my best of friend.
Her name Kelly [inaudible].
She was teaching me Arabic
and-- I mean teaching me English
and I teach her Arabic,
because she is interested.
And she speak Arabic very well
actually that time, I mean,
well enough to communicate.
I said, Kelly, hey,
could you please--
I want make a concert
and collect my leave.
I can't take it.
They need me to work in
the restaurant, I can't.
OK. So, I have no-- nothing,
I mean, absolutely zero.
I was sleeping on the carpet.
And she gave me-- not the blanket--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Sheet or--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Sheet,
exactly, and--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Pillow.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Pillow, isn't it?
That's all I have.
And oud and books.
And I told her let's do concert.
And whenever I collect so I
can buy my ticket and go back?
And she said yeah.
And so she went and rented the
hall at UNM, and then, Keller hall.
And we hired for sound guy.
And I remember one time she made
that flyer, right, and she said,
"Rahim, we have to put
the flyer on the street."
And I said, "I can't put
my flyer on the street."
"Just stay here.
Just stay here and
practice, you know?
I will do it."
>> Daniel Sheehy: Did she work
in the University of New Mexico?
>> Rahim Alhaj: No.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Or was she just--
>> Rahim Alhaj: No, she's a friend.
Actually she is a kindergarten
teacher.
Like I said, she speak Arabic
and that's why we were introduced
by mutual friend who
is actually he's here
in Washington DC, work here, anyway.
And he told her, well, this guy
is famous and [inaudible] lost
and he needs leave but
he doesn't know how.
So, whenever she has money, it
was like I think $700 or $800,
she put it just to do it to-- I get
money from this concert to go back.
So, we did the concert.
I was-- you know, practice.
In the concert, there's not a
lot of people because of oud
in Albuquerque, you
know, I can't imagine
like what you do with oud in--
>> Daniel Sheehy: In the year 2000.
>> Rahim Alhaj: In
2000, yes, exactly.
So, what you are going to do with
oud in New Mexico, in Albuquerque?
Nobody knows the oud, how
come they know Rahim AlHaj?
I was telling Kelly that time, I
said, nobody stops me on the street
or the cafés and they come
out and love your own music.
Yes, usually that's what I do.
She said, "Rahim, they do
not know the oud look like.
I said, "Huh.
Why?" How come they don't
know, because if you go
to Europe everybody
knows the oud, you know?
Anyway, I did the concert.
And I remember so vividly Kelly
was talking to the audience
because I cannot speak English.
And she talked to them and
explained the piece I will play
and it's called blah, blah,
blah, that's about, and I play.
That was it.
And a very significant
thing happened
at that time in this concert.
When I finished the concert, there's
a guy with his little boy came
to the green room holding the
program with my picture in it,
you know, program and
the picture, you know?
And the little boy was crying,
I mean, literally tears.
And I said in bad English, I said
you don't like my music, don't you?
And he said, no, I loved it
but I need your signature.
Oh, my God.
If this little boy understood
what I'm talking about,
about the suffering
of women and children,
I'm going to make a difference.
After paying, you know, the rent
for the hall and sound engineer
and flyer, I made $700 or
something, less than that, actually.
It's not even close to buy a
ticket to go back to Damascus.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right, right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: I said
to this little boy,
I'm going to make a difference.
I'm going to stay.
I said to Kelly, Kelly, look,
I don't care about money--
And still I don't care and that's
what-- my was wife mad at me.
Because $1 million and $100,000
is the same to me, I don't care,
that's why I don't
have a good shoes.
So, I told her just book me
anywhere, $100, $200, $500, $1,000,
I don't care, except I need
regular, you know, concert.
I don't care about money.
She managed me actually for
one year and she get rid of me,
she said I'm unmanageable.
[ Laughter ]
And she said now because people when
I did the concerts here and there,
you know, outpost with Tom
McNickle [assumed spelling]
who became my dear friend
and then Stephen Feld who was
at the concert actually--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah,
the ethnomusicologist?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, beautiful dear
friend and wonderful human being
and a great, great
musicology-- musicologist, sorry.
And she said we need a CD.
I said, oh, I have cassettes
but I don't have CDs.
And she booked a studio.
And we have the $300.
And she said in Arabic,
Rahim, look, we have $300
and we booked this--
this is in Arabic.
And we booked this
studio for one hour.
If you pass one minute after one
hour, they will charge us $300--
doesn't matter if you spend
one hour or one minute.
What I need from you,
to finish whole record
in one hour, do you understand?
I said, yeah.
I went there to the studio.
I did my piece.
Go there and smoked my cigarette.
Come back, just one take.
One take, whole record,
58 minutes, that's it.
And I did it.
I finished but then
I have to produce it.
I don't have money.
So they send me the mail, like, you
know, when they send you this like--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Oasis?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah,
it was like a--
>> Daniel Sheehy: And
there are two companies--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, which is
like, you know, check advance.
And they said, well, you
[inaudible] for $3,000 in the bank.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Oh, like a--
Yeah, like an advance on royalty?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, yeah.
No, no advance of check,
you know, when you--
oh, you have a credit card and--
>> Daniel Sheehy: Oh, money advance?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yes, money advance.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Then you
will have to pay it back.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Of course.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Like a loan.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah, exactly
but I didn't understand
and I told Kelly, "So,
this is my money?
I can use it?"
She said, "Yeah, you can use it.
But you have to return it back."
I said, "Yeah, but I
can use it now, right?"
She said yes.
And I said, "Well,
so I can do my CD?"
They give me $2,000.
And dear friend of mine who
was my childhood friend also,
actually he's a famous artist.
Now, he is-- actually he lives
in the United States, too,
who did the art work,
now he's a professor
at New York University in New York.
He's very famous, actually.
And he did the art work, right?
It's free.
And there is man who is
wonderful human being, engineer,
and he fell in love with me and
he fell in love and he said,
whoa this guy, something, right?
And they told him that the
guy doesn't have even $5.
He said I don't need money because--
He said, I'm going
to master it free.
So he mastered it.
And then we send it to-- and he
couldn't really afford a bar code.
It's $50. I don't have it.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Right.
>> Rahim Alhaj: So
we print the record
without bar code, because
I don't have it.
And they made 1,000 copies of that.
I sold 28,000 copies of this record.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Nice.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Within six months.
>> Daniel Sheehy: 28,000
in six months?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Six months.
>> Daniel Sheehy: That's impressive.
That's impressive.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Coming from a
record company background now?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Right.
>> Daniel Sheehy: That's impressive.
[ Laughter ]
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well, that's good.
So, now to wind up here,
that was shortly after 2000.
And here we are in 2016, what
are some of the highlights--
I know you've worked with some
enormous very distinguished artists
in the United States and beyond.
Can you just touch-base
of few of those where--
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Where is your
career gone up until today?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Actually
after that time, I really--
like I said, I'm fortunate
to be in the United States
because I have the opportunity
to communicate and collaborate
with the wonderful musicians
from around, you know?
I collaborate with-- from Rock
and Roll, REM, to Kronos Quartet,
to Robert Mirabal, a Native
American, to Spanish and--
I mean, India, China,
and everywhere.
So I have really the opportunity
to collaborate with that.
And my highlight actually
started with the record
with the Smithsonian,
actually, Folkways Recording
when they really courageously
enough they invited me
to do a traditional Iraqi
music, and I did it.
And that was really wonderful
because it was an introduction
to me to Iraqi music.
Because I was interested
to do my own in music,
I'm not interested to
do a traditional one.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Well, as I recall,
there was an interesting
discussion about that.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Right.
>> Daniel Sheehy: What was
the deal as you remember it?
>> Rahim Alhaj: Is that-- In the
beginning, I was that, you know,
that's great, I can have-- you know,
Smithsonian, I know it very well.
I know them really well and I
have huge respects for them.
And I was, you know, honored
and then excited really.
But I wanted to establish
my own composition,
that's why I'm interested.
But actually I have a question.
I don't remember you
ask me or even Atesh.
He said what do you think how
much people they have difference--
they know the differences between
your music in the Iraqi tradition?
>> Daniel Sheehy: I
know I asked that.
We both may have asked
that question.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Raul?
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Rahim Alhaj: So I think I
said, wow, that's absolutely true.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah.
>> Rahim Alhaj: So give
them the introduction
to Iraqi music, you
know, traditional.
And that's what we get
really Grammy Nomination for.
It was beautiful record.
And it has a lot of story but
we don't have time for it,
until we finished with
this beautiful record.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yes.
>> Rahim Alhaj: And last
month, actually, we--
I had the privilege actually
to have this beautiful record
called "Letter from Iraq."
And Dan Sheehy who really
wonderfully he said,
"Absolutely yes.
Send me some music."
So I sent him some music.
And you heard that.
It's about Iraqi stories with
eight letters from Iraq, from women
and children, to United States.
And I carefully painted
these letters to music.
For oud and a string orchestra,
basically, but we couldn't do it
as orchestra so we did it with the
string quintet with percussionist
at the same time, it
was [inaudible].
And that's actually the highlight
of my career in United States.
>> Daniel Sheehy: It's beautiful.
Just to-- Last question
to round this off,
what's your hope for the future?
In the United States, particularly,
but anywhere, for your music,
for culture in the United States,
just from your own personal point
of view, what's you personal hope
for the future connected
to your music?
>> Rahim Alhaj: I mean, again, I
told you that my music is about how
to make a difference in the world.
I don't care.
I don't care about money.
I don't care about fame.
I don't care.
I care when I feel there is some
difference to make on this planet.
And all of us, actually,
we are responsible
to do something good to this planet.
Because it's not just for us,
it's for generation to come.
So, by creating beauty,
creating music, creating art,
create an understanding
between all of us,
and make this world a beautiful
to generation, what a great honor,
what a great thing to do.
And I will do it until I expire,
actually, that's what I believe is
to just talk about women
and children their
stories, bring them back.
I mean, not just Iraqis and
Syrian-- around the world, actually.
Whatever I hear woman she's
sad or woman she is in need
or woman has a story nobody
heard about, I will take it
and then paint that as a music.
If I hear one children, whatever
in this planet, has a story
and nobody heard about
it, I would paint it.
I call that painting.
I don't really call it that
music, really, to be honest.
Because I'm truthful to the
story, I'm truthful to the moment,
and truthful to the history.
Because this is going to-- you know,
10 years from now,
20 years, God knows.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Yeah,
the musical portraits,
is really, really is beautiful.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Absolutely.
So my hope is to bring
peace, love, and compassion
to our crazy world right now.
Because we live really
in an unpleasant moment,
I mean the whole world, we
live in unpleasant moment.
So if we can take that
sadness away, you know,
that pressure away, whatever it is.
If I educate my neighbor
who really think
that Mexicans they don't have
electricity because they are poor
or other neighbor who I am-- for
I am Muslim and totally a cousin
of Osama bin Laden probably
-- and educating that --
no, no, no, this is my country.
And I didn't tell you the story.
It was in 2004 after
the invasion, this--
the most beautiful moment I
had when I saw my Mom again.
It was beautiful, beautiful.
So I remember 2004-- I
haven't seen her for like years
and years and years, right?
She is beautiful, gorgeous
82 years old.
I mean, gorgeous.
And one night I was just talking
to her, you know, with my hand
and my head in her lap and talking
and she's playing with my hair.
And we're talking about my
sisters and brothers -- happy.
In just one second, I
remembered New Mexico.
And all my heart is
-- just like that.
I was like, oh God, I miss this one.
I said, what is it i need?
I mean, I had chills when
I'm in my mom's lap, right?
This is what I need, so
I remember New Mexico.
And I missed it so much.
Then, I realize, this is my home.
And still.
>> Daniel Sheehy: Rahim
AlHaj, it's a pleasure
and an honor to call you habibi.
>> Rahim Alhaj: Yeah,
you're a habibi too.
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.